what's up gamers socially well-adjusted
common folk it's your boy annoying video
game vlogger here to have an over
exaggerated reaction to generally
underwhelming video game news today I'm
going to be milking two reviews the
long-awaited sequel Marable Ultimo
Allied forces order of the Phoenix in
all seriousness though I now know what
it feels like to have been those poor
Schmucks without a Playstation when that
other thing got announced I don't own a
switch because I'm too busy paying a
mortgage and trying to support your lazy
ass through college you jobless Punk
well that's not entirely true my 11 year
old sister owns a switch hey bro your
switch oh but at one point I asked
myself while working on my review for
marvel ultimate electronics one what
would the third game even be like if it
came out today then I know for sure the
guardians of the galaxy would be there
and it would be chock-full of annoying
MCU references because at this point
let's face it everything with a Marvel
label on it has now been obliterated and
replaced with marketing material for the
movies continuity be damned take a drink
every time a Marvel game comes out with
Thanos or Loki as the main bad guy so I
was right on that one but I was wrong on
my next major assumption the x-men
Deadpool and Fantastic Four would be
treated like a colony of rabies infected
lepers and exiled into wait who's that
territory and all the game's dialogue
but here's good ol Wolverine front and
center staring us down with his mighty
pulsating biceps as if to say yeah
Marvel vs. Capcom infinite was [ __ ]
Marvel fans were blindsided with this
miraculous comeback at the Game Awards
yesterday which is brought to us by the
fine folks behind the worst metroid game
and boob physics controversy I'd say
among other announcements this was the
real standout I mean what else happened
at boon continues his proud tradition of
putting horribly unfitting music for a
CG trailer for a game that I'll probably
be more excited about than all of my
friends combined his spawn gonna be a
DLC fighter this time no shut up stop
asking questions loser
nobody cares about Far Cry Fallout and I
bet it will have a battle royale
multiplayer mode and hello games
announces its newest multi hundred
dollar scam that will become a real game
like three years after the fact so I
guess we'll just stick to talking about
this one for now based on the trailer we
can see they're going for Thanos in the
black order as the
bad guys duh with cameos from daddies
like comedy robot
fist-fighting a sandstorm aka Marvel
Zombies for Splosion man Gwen Stacy's
boyfriend boring the accuser cancelled
man in the mechanical mutant phobes and
probably some other characters I'm too
inebriated to recognize I like the
Spidey suit in this game he's kind of
like that Disneyland spider-man and it's
unfortunate that this is on a competitor
console because they could have totally
cash in on some cross-promotion dlc
suits I'm a little worried that
spider-man is back to being a teenager
again though because Sandman calls him
well we all remember what I said about
advertising ain't that right Nicky jr.
hey remember when they tease that
Galactus won revenge at the end of the
first game me neither
it appears the graphics are a little
more cartoonish this time around with an
exaggerated cel-shaded style this is
likely due to the lower performance
capabilities of the oh wait we can't use
that excuse anymore when a Nintendo game
looks bad nevermind I gotta say I'm a
little disappointed by this change
because the realistic graphics of the
original games gave them a little more
seriousness in class well as this one
reminds me of Marvel strike force at
best and Disney infinity a worst well I
can't say I'm entirely surprised this
game is getting made because the
remasters for the classic games just
came out to gauge interest from players
I am however priest surprised this ended
up is an exclusive to a Nintendo console
of all things you know they actually say
that Samus and Link were supposed to be
in the Wii port of the first game maybe
that'll happen now who knows it's not
like Nintendo's afraid of crossovers
unlike Todd McFarlane and Ed Boon
apparently but overall the style and
execution the game from this trailer
alone looks pretty iffy I don't want to
jump to conclusions just yet but my
cynical caffeine addled mind is already
conjuring up some scary possibilities
thankfully though this is apparently not
the big square Enix Avengers project
announced back in 1933 so if this
doesn't quite do for you there will be
another game for comic book Twitter to
overhype and make super annoying right
around the corner when they announce in
the next twenty three days it's
unfortunate that Ultimate Alliance will
be an exclusive to the weird tablet
console with all the sticky fingerprints
and glitter on it but it's nice to see
we finally got our
damn sequel after so many years of
begging long pasture the days were you
and three friends huddle around a TV
under an overpass in the cold of winter
taking turns one at a time to play
Marvel heroes Omega to satiate your
infinite hunger for more superhero RPG
gameplay the thirst in our veins and
incessant itching on our faces has
finally been quenched scratched by this
red-hot injection of juicy wait what if
this game has a shitload of
microtransactions oh happy holiday is
missing a merry Kwanzaa limited run
Christmas merch is now available in the
store with designs by my good buddy Joey
they're all currently on sale and if you
get them into the next three days you
can get them shipped in time to put
under the tree for that special someone
with terrible taste and youtubers please
consider buying some of the merch it
really helps me out the link is in the
description
[Music]
[Music]